you must have so much street cred with
them though because like my like
cousins and nephews they all want to be
youtubers
yeah and they're all absolutely yeah i
know right it's adorable
i'm really scared because like my my
second cousin here
he just turned like six or seven yeah so
like he's about to like you know he's in
[ __ ] elementary school it's great
i love it and it's like all elementary
school kids here in japan want to be
youtubers
so i am dreading the day where he
figures out that i'm a youtuber
no it's great because that's it
he's a youtuber by the way like who is
he paying attention which part of the
family is he from again sorry
did you play fortnite as well by the way
that's great yeah it's really funny i
don't know they're just immediately like
hello
i'm paying attention unfortunately my uh
my
a lot of my nieces and nephews didn't
take after me a lot of them are just
like
jocks who love sports and stuff and
they're just i'm just like oh
never get never get a job never get a
job man
[ __ ] god this is crazy though that all
the kids want to be youtubers now
was it like 35 of japanese kids want to
be youtubers yeah
yeah because i was googling it for the
uk as well i got curious and there was
like youtuber wasn't on there it was all
like doctor
nurse something like this [ __ ] they
didn't [ __ ] they didn't give these
kids a prompt give them the prompt
tell them they could be a youtuber i bet
they'll do it i don't know it's like
being a youtuber still
looked down at one in the uk because i
haven't been there for like a long time
i don't know does it look down upon
america like would you say it is or is
it kind of like
oh i think it's neat i think they they
claim it to be cool and neat
yeah i mean it's considered cool and
neat here for the younger generation
right right yeah but the older
generation are like that's not a joke
that's not a job
yeah and there's still some of that in
the uk i think yeah yeah yeah and the
problem but the problem with that notion
especially in japan is that
the old people who say that are the
majority of the people who live here
you know so it's still considered like
okay yeah i guess this is like
the new generation job kind of thing but
yeah we'll never [ __ ] understand
in japan i'd say youtubers receive cred
when they go on national television
which it happens a lot in japan like
i've noticed yeah yeah the moment like
sucking for example the prime example
started going on the variety shows
that's when everybody's like wow that's
amazing and he edits on his own videos
he works like 82 hours a week and i'm
like [ __ ] that's all
yeah i think i think from the surface
level it's easy thing what a [ __ ]
bunch of weird areas but like when you
actually see all the work and you can
like
actually see that they're like talented
at what they do i mean not me but
you can you know you can really
appreciate what's going on it's
hilarious though to see like all these
like traditionalist like japanese tv
presenters being like wait
so you're your own editor and your own
producer and your own
cameraman and your own cameraman no
no we don't believe that [ __ ]